Let's introduce a new string method that works with lists, join().
Join takes a list as an argument and returns a string
consisting of the list elements joined by separator string.
In this example, we use a string,
backslash and as a separator,
so that there's a new line between each element, fore,
new line, aft, new line,
starboard, new line, port.
We can also use other strings as separators with join.
Here, we use a hyphen.
It's important to remember to separate each of
the items in the list you're joining with a comma.
Forgetting to do so will not trigger an error,
but will also give you unexpected results.
In the example below,
omitting a comma between Garcia and O'Kelley results in the following;
Notice how the hyphen separator is missing between Garcia and O'Kelley,
and instead, the two strings were appended.
This happens because of Python's default string literal appending.
If join returns different results than expected,
check for missing commas.
Also, note that join will trigger an error,
if we tried to join anything other than strings.
We get an error here because an integer was included in the lists.
Lastly, a helpful method called append,
adds an element to the end of the lists.
Next, you'll practice working with lists and explore more list methods.